[Music]  oddly impacting vibranium based trauma  permanent loss of hearing and dignity  next she's just scratching come on  applied topical ointment in a band-aid  I'm gonna check for rabies then next  I'm a doctor not a mechanic if it's it  looks bad looks very bad  I'm sorry time he's my friend so was i  oh wow that's a broken heart and I'm  afraid there's no medical treatment for  that but um maybe a distraction would  help I mean perhaps you can see a new  from the device reality with my many  visuals and all-star cast in here that  dares to accomplish the impossible  Cheers suggesting yeah let me how'd she  do it no it's one of many this doesn't  make any sense  not everything does  [Music]